immigration j'arrête l'immigration je
veux l'immigration zéro immigration zéro
tout le monde tout le monde dit que
c'est une chaussure qui n'a aucun sens
juridique améris qu'elle impose de
remettre en cause certains textes
fondamentaux vous le savez pertinemment
absolument et donc remettrait en l'air
menton mathieu textes fondamentaux
excusez moi mais c'est la déclaration
des droits de l'homme je sais je sais
monsieur attendait mais c'est important
de le dire mais c'est mais je vais le
bac vous vous le président remis à ban
donnes ton ce pilier de la démocratie
qu'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme car monsieur le pilier de la
démocratie c'est le peuple
d'accord démocratie s'est réfugié
déclaration d'une immense c'est le
peuple c'est les représentants du
peloton c'est l'assemblée attendez
attendez attendez attendez attendez
je ne remet absolument pas en cause la
déclaration des droits de l'homme je ne
remet absolument pas en cause les
principes mêmes de l'état devant je
remets en cause en revanche
la liberté qu'on les juge on sait qu'on
sionnel conseil d'état et c'est
d'imposer leur doxa au peuple qui n'en
veut pas donc à partir de maintenant
nous ferons un référendum le peuple
tranchera je mettrai toutes les mesures
que j'encours que je propose c'est à
dire la fin du regroupement familial
parce que vous avez raison tout cela
l'immigration zéro est impossible vous
avez tout à fait raison dans lesquelles
il voit à tout non dans le cadre
juridique actuel et nous avons pris ce
mot et vous devriez vous avons pris le
bon moi je change le cadre jury changer
la constitution non non vous savez au
temps du général de gaulle je crois
qu'ils connaissent et un peu sa
constitution n'avait fait oui il peut
plus que jamais le conseil constitionnel
nos réflexes que vous dites c'est à dire
que le concept fonctionne elle ne se
permettait pas de prendre un principe
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme pour juger une loi parce que ce
n'était pas prévu dans le cadre
constitutionnel
c'est le juge concerné le cas inventé ce
rôle le 16 juillet 71 je peux vous faire
tout l'historique j'ai déjà beaucoup
elle subit donc donc c outre ce
judiciaire donc moi je vous dis au
conseil constitionnel à partir de
maintenant sur les sujets comme
l'immigration qui engage la survie de la
france
je demande au peuple de trancher et vous
savez qu'il ya puisque vous parlez du
droit une jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel de 1962 qui dit quand le
peuple s'exprime par référendum ils
demandent occupe depuis depuis cette
disposition n'a plus jamais été ils ont
égalisé eh ben je leur quand je leur dis
surtout que excuses excusez moi mais
qu'elle garde fous
avez-vous dès lors que vous supprimez
l'impression le conseil constitutionnel
ecoutez-moi deux choses de choses vous
savez le droit encore une fois j'ai pris
cette comparaison
je crois en usante le droit ce n'est pas
les tables de la loi descendu du mont
sinaï c'est une veine on a les marxistes
disait jadis que c'était le produit des
rapports de force de la société ce n'est
pas ça ne tombe pas du ciel vous savez
qui est président du conseil
constitionnel aujourd'hui monsieur
fabuleux family ancien premier ministre
socialiste vous savez qui est président
de la cour des comptes monsieur
moscovici ancien ministre socialiste
vous savez qui est président
vice-président puisqu'il n'ya pas
byzance et
démonstrations jeux vous enlevez jeu qui
est vice-président du conseil d'état
monsieur tabarot qui était un ancien
membre des cabinets de madame aubry et
de monsieur kouchner donc en vérité
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
l'état de droit c'est l'étape socialiste
ce sont les socialistes qui ne
représente plus que 3 % dans le pays qui
dirige le pays et vient à travers les
radios c'est à dire à travers l'état de
politique à travers l'état de droit les
juges qui sont dirigées par des
socialistes
excusez-moi imposent leur vision
n'est pas ma question référendum par le
peuvent vous voulez redonner le pouvoir
au peuple je comprends tout à fait la
géla l'indien mais dès lors qu'une le
pilier de la de la démocratie actuelle
c'est une sorte de contrôle des lois pas
en effet des juges il ya soit leur avis
sur la base de textes fondamentaux
encore il voit sharma président enlevez
vous ce garde-fou
cdd conséquence il est ce que vous
trouvez normal que au nom du principe de
fraternité liberté égalité fraternité
le conseil constitutionnel est absous un
passeur de clandestins est ce que vous
trouvez normal qu'au nom des grands
principes la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme nous ait empêché d'expulser
vers l'algérie un jihadiste moi je ne
trouve pas ça normal
[Musique]